Speaker 1: Let's talk about an incredible uh oh.
What is it? It's sort of like a set, like a like a
circular firing squad that's
taking place. Republicans
are increasingly worried that maybe they're not
going to do so well in November of 2022. Why?
Well, because the polling says they might not do
so well. And so people like Marjorie Taylor GREENE
are now saying, I don't know that that many
Republicans are going to vote, which may be
true. And then she immediately repeats the big
lie that the 2020 election was stolen, which
would only encourage Republicans not to vote.
Well, what do I mean by that? If you believe
your vote doesn't matter because it's going to be
stolen or eaten or flushed or whatever, then you
are less likely to go out and vote. If I knew, my
vote wouldn't count, why am I going to take time
to go out and vote? So even though they're worried
about low turnout, Republicans are lowering
turnout by insisting on the big lie. Here's a
clip from Marjorie Taylor GREENE on Graham Allen's
Dear America podcast. I'm not familiar with the
show, but she she appeared on it. Check this out.
It's like a cognitive dissonance almost.
Speaker 2: I'm a little more cautious. So am
I. I don't know. I'm going to be a big red wave,
but. But maybe it will be. But I'll tell you,
the biggest problem I'm concerned about is I'm
concerned about the people that are still angry
and don't want to vote. Right. And we need them to
vote because no matter I mean I mean, I was one of
the first people that I'll tell you, I don't
believe the election results of 2020. I know.
Speaker 3: We know.
Speaker 2: I believe Trump
won. I objected proudly on January 6th, and I
would do it again today and tomorrow if I could.
But but I think there's people that feel
that way and they're still angry and they and
they may not want to vote, but we have to if we
don't vote, we are handing over victory to the
radical godless left. And so to me, that's one
of my concerns is I'm worried people won't vote.
Speaker 1: Yeah, listen, guys, I'm very worried
people won't vote because they were angry that
the election was stolen and their votes didn't
count and it was stolen and their votes didn't
count. And I'm furious. Furious, furious about
that. But we need people to vote. Well, but why
would they vote if their votes are going to be
stolen and not counted or whatever? This strategy
probably lost them. The Senate, if you go back and
think about the 2020 election, there were the two
special elections in Georgia. There were it. These
are the seats ultimately won by Raphael Warnock
and Jon Ossoff. It was January 5th of 2021.
They spent the period between November of 2020
and January five, 2021, insisting that their votes
didn't count, that the entire thing is rigged,
that they're going to steal it again, and that
depress turnout and ultimately they did lose in
some of those races were not I don't remember the
exact number. Let me see if I can even find them.
January five, 2021. Special Georgia
Election Results. Let's see what those were.
Ultimately, Ossoff won. Ossoff won by 1.2
percentage points and Warnock won by two. Okay.
It is completely plausible that insisting that it
was all stolen and it's all rigged for two months
plus two months, basically between the November
election and the January special elections, that
they lost control of the Senate. Because of that,
it could be 52 to 48 Republicans were it not for
this very strategy. And now Marjorie Taylor GREENE
just repeats it. She is encouraging people not
to vote by saying it was stolen. The votes didn't
count, on and on and on. I don't believe in overt
voter suppression as a tactic to win elections.
So you will never hear me say on this show
stuff to try to trick Republicans into not voting.
I know that there are people who say, well,
the ends justify the means, and there are some
on the left who say it would be fine to try to
trick Republicans into thinking Election Day is
a different day than it is or whatever. That's
that's beneath me. I can't do that. That that
seems immoral to me, but I'm certainly not going
to tell Republicans not to do it themselves. And
if they want to continue insisting, insisting,
insisting that it was stolen, votes don't count.
It could happen again. It's all going to be fraud
then by all means, let them go ahead and do that
and see what the what the actual turnout is.